your first film a feature film was
murdered innocent murdered innocence
it's kind of like I lost my virginity
okay she called you out literally okay
yeah I was funny I was um I was I had
made short films I had made a thing with
Adam I did a short adam sandler cuz he
was I was he was a SNL and I had this
real I put together of just anything and
everything I could shoot I had a PSA and
and I was I was obsessively trying to
put this reel together because I thought
the reel was gonna be the way I I got to
be a filmmaker I had in my head from
being at NYU that all my favorite
filmmakers Scorsese Coppola Spielberg
like everyone had made a movie before
they were 30 and I had this like
self-inflicted I have to do with him oh
that's it I'm not gonna make it and I
lose in the other thing room like 20
hours and I had some weird visual
reaction seizure thing and I gotta rush
to the emergency room and while I was in
the hospital i sat there and i thought
the dumbest thing i've ever thought was
like that does a number I go if I'm
really a filmmaker I don't care if I'm
40 50 60 70 I'm never gonna stop until I
make movies and it was almost like I had
to have that revelation because the
following week I was on Long Island with
my girlfriend at the time and a video
story I think it was a blockbuster they
were still around and I turned the
corner and this guy's hitting on my
girlfriend and he's like I'm a filmmaker
and the reason and then I'm like yeah
I'm a filmmaker too he said yeah what'd
you do I go you want to see my reel he's
like yeah I'll see you real and then he
saw my reel and he had it was this guy
Fred Carbon who had made a bunch of
Indies on Long Island and he goes that
you're good man
you wanna you want to direct this movie
you have 14 days and we have like you
know $200,000 I'm like carried the
script I'm like yeah so I read the
script and it was just like really bad
police drama and I had seen his other
movies and they were kind of these weird
B movies were always Gary Bergdorf as a
serial killer
best at zero killer I thought kind of
cool my first opportunity to make a
weird movie
I read the script it was all like police
talk but kind of like corny TV police
talk so I I called up one of my buddies
from NYU Steve perros and he'll read the
script I get to make this movie but the
script is not good at all and they go
well you rewrite and I'm like yeah and
I'm like she do you think and then he
goes well you love film noir and I'm
like yeah it's like this kind of corny
dialogue can be easily shifted to like
varnish kind of dialog and it had this
whole flashback of murder that happened
in the 70s and so we we whole I said I'm
gonna rewrite he goes you have two weeks
to rewrite it we rewrote it and we had
Jason Miller was cast in it who was the
priest in The Exorcist he was nominated
for that and he also wrote that
championship season beautiful man he
passed away a few years back he loved
what I did with the script it had a lot
of depth it was a dark dark story I
think we got a seventeen body count by
the end of movie it had to have that I
had to kill a bunch of people I had a
blow-up a car and so we made the story
with the parameters that the producer
one and the other parameter was the
producer had to be the lead oh wow
and so we wrote a role that you know we
kind of made him under his breath and
then he blows up and gets angry and and
I kind of we put together a movie that
was like kind of weird and cool very
blue velvet influence cuz I had seen
that at the time so it was quirky weird
talked about totally strange movie and
you know I didn't get to cast everyone I
wanted it was like the visual effects
the special effects guy had to be the
bad guy so the level of talent was a
little bit all over the place so because
I knew that I played it a bit campy
again with blue velvet as an inspiration
and so it was this weird dark kind of
funny movie which has one of my favorite
final shots in it because I was a huge
fan of the Graduate and my favorite last
shot of that movie is he finally gets
the girl and the two of them on the back
of the bus and and Mike Nichols is
it just leaves the camera on them till
it just gets uncomfortable and this home
I might in my movie they're doing all
the stuff running killing other and they
finally get away the girl and the guy
and the camera does this creepy just
pull back and inspired by my my pickles
shot and and it's like okay now they
have each other now what but yeah I got
to make this cool movie and the first
time you make a feature film you think
something about if you really want to be
a filmmaker the scariest thing in the
world is to make a feature film because
you could think how can I hold all this
in my head
and I did it and I was like this cool
and then Columbia TriStar had seen in
his days of home video and they bought
it immediately and they got it went to
Home Video I don't think it's available
on blu-ray or anything now but it would
be great for us I I just got honored in
the festival in Switzerland then they
showed it so the first time I had seen
it years in front of an audience it was
dubbed in German seemed to go over
pretty good okay so so you literally got
this job by being at a blockbuster video
yeah and having a hot girlfriend I guess
did you believe and what going back it
was Fred Carpenter yeah and that's what
was so did you believe him at that point
like when he died I think I was I was in
my hometown my parents had showed me an
article hey look at this I was in films
you know I came out of film school look
at this guy in our town it was like an
expose and Newsday or something and so I
knew I kind of knew small town I grew up
and I was like oh yeah that's that guy
yeah and then you co you then helped
reshape the script yeah and the funny
thing is is so I had like I didn't even
have a real crew we had like a guy who
did like our gaffer did like industrials
you know is this about long deep Wang
Island and the crew was all Hofstra
students and they were like first
second-year students they didn't even
have the equipment that I had at NYU's
they were like really green and but I'm
good at rallying the troops and getting
them to believe in the movie and
14 days shoot went for like 38 days
because I got people to work for free
for me and you know but like I bought in
with film it was like that kind of thing
where like I used my credit cards and
you know I didn't take any money I think
I was supposed to get paid I need to
direct it and I just put that into the
film and yeah Lenny Weintraub was this
an investor he was a real really sweet
real estate guy and he invested in the
movie and was excited to be a part of
Hollywood weren't quite Hollywood then
but there was some relaxants Ellen green
she was if the at Racal actress she was
in the movie she was in like Little Shop
of Horrors on Broadway then around that
time yeah so we just we just pulled the
pulled it off cut it on film
my editor Tom Lewis has edited most of
my movies yeah they like film school
buddy yeah the guy who was a
cinematographer on my travel
documentaries was the cinematographer so
there was a bunch of NYU people came
together to help me out so it goes to
home video how long before then you get
your next job which is the wedding sings
so meanwhile
you